le secteur de la production d'énergie
est parvenu à stabiliser ses émissions
de gaz à effet de serre l'an dernier
malgré une croissance économique
mondiale qui a frisé les 3 % les rejets
de dioxyde de carbone n'ont pas grimpé
ils ont atteint 30 3 gigatonnes la même
quantité qu'en 2018
la principale cause le passage aux
énergies renouvelables comme l'éolien et
le solaire
le recours au gaz naturel et au
nucléaire plutôt qu au charbon les
émissions de co2 ont baissé de 5% en
europe 2 4% au japon et de 3% aux
etats-unis
les émissions ont cependant augmenté
ailleurs dans le monde l'utilisation du
charbon progresse notamment en asie
[Musique]